I'm being told that we can bring you
footage
now of the attacker
we know we can see that he is
brandishing a knife
he is being pursued looks like by a
passerby there trying to
apprehend him this is clearly before the
police intervention we saw masses of
police there but this was clearly
earlier
[Music]
presumably after the attack took place
we know that the attacker is a Syrian
National he has legal Refugee status he
is in custody but two children and an
adult are in a critical condition
fighting for their lives in hospital
we'll be bringing you all of the updates
on a press conference from anisee at the
top of the hour